well let's be clear decisions on  individual taxes are for our independent  hmrc but we're talking about taxes that  google paid on profits in the years 2005  to 2011 by the way those were years when  this government wasn't even in office  now we've got the tanks being paid and  the HMRC says that's the right amount of  tax for the profits made by google back  then these taxes are being paid on  profits that were made under a Labour  government and no tax was collected by  that Labour government now those taxes  are being collected under a Conservative  government because we've taken this  action to make sure companies pay their  fair share of taxes I take other  companies to follow suit